bonjour gad elmaleh d'ailleurs c'est
quoi ce pull alors le problème des pulls
de noël c'est qu'on ne peut pas les
porter sans avoir des réflexions sur le
pull de noël et c'est ça finalement
c'est un vêtement qui crée l'événement
quoi je suis pas là pour ventes de puces
pourquoi tu me suis beaucoup impliqué
vestimentaire dans parlant je voulais
être là ce matin je voulais marquer
cette période parce pub qui apporte de
la joie dans un moment où beaucoup de
tension d'adversité de froid de je crois
que c'est réussi merci d'être venu c'est
la journée mondiale de la raclette oui
gré vous entre cette suisse à la base
avec du fromage bien sûr on ne présente
plus qui séduit énormément de français
dès le plus jeune âge alors pour avoir
l'occasion d'en manger des collégiens de
moselle se sont battus pendant plusieurs
semaines ils ont même lancé une pétition
pour exiger la raclette à la cantine
après deux mois et demi de bataille le
voeu des élèves est exaucé ce midi au
menu c'est raclette c'est trop bien
parce que d'habitude en fut passeur
quand je reviens jamais la raclette et
là bas pour une fois yann algan c'est
trop bien si elle ne mange pas les
croûtes moi je veux bien lancé par un
mouvement de collecte des croûtes
value c'est le sait le message du genre
quand vous faites griller la craqueront
rien ce délicieux la crau je suis bien
raccordé
135 kg de pommes de terre soit 115 kilos
de fromage et autant de charcuterie
grâce aux parents d'élèves et
entreprises locales qui ont tous fourni
gratuitement
l'initiative a aussi donné des idées
nous aurons
en attendant
eric zemmour lui continue ses
déplacements pour son premier voyage
officiel de campagne à l'étranger il a
choisi de l'arménie sur place depuis
trois jours le candidat a voulu saluer
et saluer nation chrétienne au milieu
d'un océan islamique voyage qui fait
polémique nicolas sarkozy sur tous les
arméniens nous aura mythe pas tous les
quatre matins comme hostile aux autres
non mais c'est vrai
durante memoriae l'armée noble âge
langage s'il vous plaît ici c'est pas on
n'est pas la foire à neuneu hamon
arnaud montebourg lance lui aussi un
appel à l'union directement avec son
téléphone
le diviseur ce ne sera pas lui
bonjour jean luxembourg bonjour il ya
dix jours fabien c'est arnaud montebourg
quatre appels et 4 répondeur ça serait
bien qu'on se parle peux-tu me rappelais
amitié seuls deux candidats l'ont
finalement rappelé un bilan bien maigre
pour l'union de la gauche on va voir
s'il ya un répondeur j'espère
on continue la blague ardo oui bonjour
c'est pascal praud ça serait bien qu'on
se parle quand même
aujourd'hui essayons de nous rappeler
amitié est ce que c'est une femme
célibataire keira à l'elysée oui c'est
une femme célibataire mais je veux dire
ça dans votre vie je ne considère pas
mais d'abord ça ça vous regarde pas
enfin c'est quand même incroyable j'ai
dit ah quand même une vie privée moi je
suis désolé je suis attaché quand
j'étais encore une vip moi je suis la
république s'est compliqué la vie privée
la non je suis pas d'accord je suis
désolé je considère que
il ya une vie privée mais pour ça il
faut aussi avoir une décence dans le
comportement alimentaire oui peut-être
sur vous savez le droit de yom
pourquoi pour la france ces français
tous les suspects et les spectateurs qui
vont être ravis alors je précise qu' il
faut être célibataire selon l'état civil
pour miss france d'accord moi je suis
célibataire or l'état civil mais pour
disney france et seulement l'état ciel
un solitude effrayer dame de 20 ans je
me sens point la mienne assez grande
assez forte pour
mémoire montech salaire
pour me résoudre à prendre un dessin de
l'aca voilà un
petit trou mais vers mutilé il a eu lui
avaient pas là ils pouvaient pas pour
maintenant mais souhaitait un souffleur
ma première télé jeux thq grande
angoisse j'attends bayer est là pas du
tout moi je dirais alors j'ai répondu
très honnêtement cette question c'est
que je sais que ma maman il ya des miss
qui veulent pas forcément répondre moi
je vis je suis célibataire maintenant je
ne suis pas un coeur à prendre je vient
d'accueillir beaucoup de français dans
mon coeur c'est pas forcément le temps
pour quelqu'un c'est à dire dubaï et des
châssis
ta vie' est impose l'étrange qui un jour
s'emboîtant vous c'est ce que me disait
hier matin le barrage de la vie a du mal
à s'emboîter en moi c'est très
philosophique on n'a pas mis les
passages aujourd'hui il mériterait elle
et lui ouais le clac
pas les seuls d'ailleurs parce qu'il y
avait un truc ou enfin aujourd'hui par
exemple évidemment avec l'âge que j'ai
aujourd'hui l'expérience que j'ai eue
honnêtement je serais intervenu parce
que c'est ultra jamais l'impression
d'être la petite jeune on tour est de
ces hommes là et avec des questions et
d'ailleurs la première question qui est
qui vient d'une femme qui est vous avez
coucher pour réussir
et sert une soupe que vous avez des
chiffres
[Applaudissements]
je vais boire je n'ai pu résister au
foot par exemple ou des seins ça me
poserait moins trois la chine j'en ai
une la
faute sur moi
ça suive ou non c'est bien
bon alors en fait voilà il faut ouvrir
la porte voilà et là il ya une pompe
voilà et
voilà voilà et alors alors le petit
personnage fait pipi
c'est évident et lors la dame mais la
dame s'est voilà alors s et du lait
c'est quoi non mais ce qu'on veut mais
ce qu'on veut c'est sur la porte en fait
quand vous appuyez sur la porte voilà ça
déclenche à l'organisme c'est chic ce
concours de beauté est exclusivement
réservé aux chameaux organisé dans le
désert sur 32 km carrés c'est le plus
grand rassemblement rassemblement du
monde de ce genre sixième édition 33
mille participants donc et 43 viennent
d'être disqualifié suite à des
injections de botox c'est très sérieux
regardez ces images ça ressemble à ça un
chameau des toxines et les
fenêtres
les merlus
ça va vraiment beaucoup trop loin c'est
la folie bataille où le reste ça va t on
à plein
temps
[Musique]
ok ça va j'ai pas aimé ça j'ai pas aimé
ce qui s'est passé pas du jeu monsieur
brûler ce
nom mais il faut aller
le g insulte pour un empoté empâté pipe
espèce de gros gland gros plein de soupe
mineurs prix versé cet homme a profité
de voir sa compagne sur un bateau pour
lui faire sa demande en mariage
un cadre plutôt sympa mais c'était sans
compter sur le petit coup deux ans sur
le levier de la marche arrière